how does the voting system in the
council of the european union work
the council is made up of member state
representatives
who meet regularly to adopt and discuss
eu legislation
decisions at council meetings are taken
by vote
the council can only vote if a majority
of its members is present
15 out of 28.
there are three types of voting
procedure simple majority
qualified majority and unanimity
simple majority voting is used for
procedural issues
such as the rules governing council
committees
it requires the majority of member
states 15 out of a total of 28
to vote in favor of the proposal
qualified majority is used for the 80 of
eu legislation
adopted through the ordinary legislative
procedure also known as co-decision
a qualified majority is reached if two
conditions are met
55 percent of member states vote in
favor in practice this means
16 out of 28. the proposal is supported
by member states representing at least
65
of the total eu population this is the
double majority rule
proposals can be blocked by a group of
at least four member states
representing more than 35 percent of the
eu population
this is called a blocking minority
not that complicated but wait there's a
catch
this qualified majority rule is in use
from november 2014
but until 2017 member states can still
request to use the previous rule
under this rule each member state has a
certain number of votes
based on their population size reaching
a qualified majority
needs votes out of a total of 352
from at least 15 member states
now for unanimity i guess it's pretty
self-explanatory
it requires everyone to agree or abstain
if a council member abstains the other
ministers can still reach unanimity
unanimity voting is used for some
specific areas
mentioned in the eu treaties such as
citizenship
eu membership and taxation
after the council votes on legislative
texts the results are immediately made
available to the public
now you know how voting in the council
of the eu works
find out more on the website at
concillium.europa.eu
you